before the video starts please help me
to reach my target of thirty thousand
pounds for afghanistan's emergency
appearable sisters inshallah how can we
eat in peace knowing that they are
starving
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah this is
a somali brother uh who is basically um
does videos on tik tok who's maybe an
entertainer or whatever i've i scrolled
through some of his stuff it's just
mainly dancing and music
etc uh but some comments that i was just
scrolling for i found it a little bit
disturbing uh because i do know how
some people a lot of people can be
judgmental uh you know but i wanted to
put few things in the perspective here
because it's very important sometimes we
don't realize and understand the damage
that we can do to our own self while we
might like the uh dislike the actions of
others
and then what happens is you are the one
that ends up losing you know uh so i
just want to put a few things into
perspective here uh number one um that
of course that for example it is not
difficult for uh the opposite genders to
be imitating the other um so that's one
thing that's clear in our religion you
know there's a heli for the prophet
peace be upon him which makes that very
clear uh that you know somebody who you
know
um
wears the clothes of the opposite gender
so it's not permissible etc but for
example one thing that we need to bear
in mind here is this that
just because somebody acts a certain way
be it a female or be a male
for us to label them give them names
back by them slander them now this is a
matter of standard because there are
people in those comments section uh who
are literally calling this person
gay
you know at the end of the day in islam
islam takes slander very very
yeah it's it's very heavy you know it's
not something that's like
slander specifically uh about uh it's
about women basically one of the seven
major sins uh that there's a hadith
about the process mentioned this is even
in surah nur in the quran
talks about slander very very harshly
you know and there's a punishment of 80
lashes for anybody that slanders a
chaste woman now this doesn't mean it's
just for women obviously slandering a a
man could be you know there could be
great consequences as well so we need to
bear in mind just because someone acts
in a certain way or behaves in a certain
way you in no way shape or form are
allowed to call that person a name or
spread rumors about that person it says
haram you are not allowed to do it
period now if you don't like that person
i think it's very silly if you're
someone that believes that you are going
to be backbiting someone you don't like
because if you understood what the
consequence of backbiting is is that
they will get your good deeds now not
only that if you have no good deeds left
you'll be carrying their sins
so if this person is committing sins by
doing this let's argument say you know
it's it's not permissible you know let's
say the way he's conducting himself etc
let's suppose he's falling to sins and
he's accumulating the sins those sins
well hundreds or thousands of you guys
are calling him gay or calling him this
or that etc under their judgment you
might end up carrying all the sins that
he's done
so the point is why would you go down
that route now when i see that i'm not
saying like when i see this person like
he's a muslim brother to me and at the
end of the day you know believers have
to be you know close with each other and
love one another yes this stuff he's
doing i don't approve it like to me it's
like i'm like it's better if he didn't
do it um i'm not just talking about the
whole music and dancing thing like again
yeah that is distasteful and it can be
classed as haram but other stuff is well
um but again
why need to make clear is brothers and
sisters sometimes a person might have
personal issues that is going in his
life and they express it in different
ways now i'm not saying that makes it
permissible what i'm just saying is
sometimes we can just apply good
assumptions applying good assumptions
doesn't mean that the action itself
isn't no it can be haram but we can try
to give good assumptions etc and advice
so maybe he will be watching this video
aki you know you are brother we have
nothing but love for me personally now
coming to you my dear brother i just
want to advise you inshallah because
there was a video which went that i
found
a little bit very disturbing you know
and i just wanted to share that with all
without you know just as a brotherly
advice to you you know it's one that
you're drinking a
something in starbucks and you're
you know the way you're uh how can i say
your interaction with the straw uh was
quite disturbing to me you know um and
now you need to bear in mind that the
prophet peace be upon him once left
walking with his wife and some companies
saw him and he went to those companions
and he said just to let you guys know
this is my wife you know just so
there is no doubt you know people
there's no question mark and they said
oh messenger of allah how could like of
course we know is your wife how could we
think otherwise he said shaytan runs in
the blood uh of adam in the veins of
adam so meaning the shaytan can come
this doesn't give an excuse for people
to back but it will slander you but you
need to understand if there's certain
things that you're doing it's as if you
are opening those
doors
um yeah
um like i said before it's not
permissible for anyone to slander back
by you but for you to go and
do certain things what it does is it
leaves people a bit confused you know
and when people are asked without like
wanting to back by you and say look you
know do you think this person can be
like that they might be like
we don't know so the per the the point
i'm trying to make here bro is that we
need the way we carry ourself we can't
leave doubt in people's minds do you
have transcendent assume the best i
can't be running around with a girl you
know um argument's sake she was a
miniscule exception i got no just assume
the best assume the best work brother
you know sometimes we need to judge from
what's apparent and once again this
doesn't mean you back bite the point is
that i
might be playing a role in what they're
doing i might be causing it uh you know
like and i'll wrap up on this inshallah
like if we saw somebody's mother in
islam and if they insult my mother back
i carry the sin of him and show to my
mom as well because i caused it so what
i'm just saying is brother please just
be a bit careful i understand um and you
know may allah bless you and your family
inshaallah i just thought i'll share
this with you guys inshaallah please
let's be very careful and maybe share
these videos with with him inshallah and
you can see that's what i want to share
with you guys back by to islam this
major sin guys stay away from it for
your
uh until next
alaikum